الى الضفه الغربيه حيث حذر تقرير صادر عن
مفوضيه الامم المتحده لحقوق الانسان من
التدهور السريع لحاله حقوق الانسان في
الضفه داعيا الى انهاء العنف واكد التقرير
مقتل 300 فلسطيني منهم
88 طفلا في الضفه الغربيه والقدس منذ
السابع من اكتوبر تشرين الاول الماضي
واضاف ان القوات الاسرائيليه اعتقلت اكثر
من 4700 فل يني من بينهم 44 صحفيا في
القدس وباقي مناطق الضفه الغربيه ودع
التقرير اسرائيل الى وضع حد لعمليات القتل
غير المشروع وعنف المستوطنين ضد السكان
الفلسطينيين كما دعا الى وضع حد فوري
لاستخدام الاسلحه العسكريه والوسائل
العسكريه ووضع حد للاحتجاز التعسفي واساءه
معامله
الفلسطينيين واعتبرت تقرير ان تجريد
الفلسطينيين من انسانيتهم امر مقلق للغايه
ويجب ان يتوقف
فورا